[Music]
hi guys i'm jasmine and today i'm going
to be showing you how to make three
really fun and colorful cotton candy
recipes you might have seen some awesome
cotton candy treats from all around the
world over on bring me but we can't
travel so today we're gonna make them
right from home let's get started
so we're gonna start with the simple
cotton candy rain cloud i saw this pop
up on my instagram a while back i
thought it was really cool so i wanted
to recreate it the cafe puts coffee
under this white cotton candy that looks
like a perfect little cloud and the
steam melts the cotton candy so that
it's literally raining sugar into the
coffee i however am not a big coffee
drinker so i'm replacing the coffee with
royal milk tea today if you don't like
tea you can use coffee or whatever hot
fabric you want
all right let's make some cotton candy i
got this candy literally just for this
video and i am so happy my inner child
is screaming all right so we're gonna
start by adding one hard yellow candy
and one tablespoon of super fine white
sugar to the center of the cotton candy
machine
the machine is going to melt down the
candies in the center there and when it
flings out the speed of the spinning
will make it super thin and fluffy and
we're going to roll it up like this
trying to get it to look like a super
beautiful cloud
we have our cloud look how cute it is it
looks just like a cloud and it looks so
nice and fluffy i want to eat it right
now so now i'm just gonna put it on this
table sign holder and we're gonna set it
aside while we make our royal milk tea
we're gonna add a third cup of boiling
water over one tablespoon of awesome
black tea leaves we're gonna let this
sit for two to three minutes and the
leaves will begin to open up and that
will help bring the flavors forward now
i'm grabbing a small pot and we're gonna
add in one and a quarter cup of milk
our steep tea
and one teaspoon of sugar
just gonna give it a little mix
and royal milk tea is different from
regular milk tea with regular milk tea
we usually steep the tea and add in the
milk after we're done for royal milk tea
we are boiling the milk and the tea
together i'm gonna cover my pot and let
it heat up until it reaches
about right before boiling point so
while we wait for that let's preheat our
tea cup so our tea can stay nice and hot
the hotter the tea the bigger the
rainfall from our cotton candy cloud
just gonna grab my teacup pour some hot
water in there and we'll empty it before
we pour in the royal milk tea all right
time to make it rain you guys i'm gonna
pour in the royal milk tea into my
preheated cup here now we're gonna place
it underneath the cotton candy and let
the magic be good
[Music]
so
[Music]
cheers let's give it a taste
super creamy very rich especially if you
have good quality tea leaves it's not
overly sweet as one might think and also
come on this was so fun
so for this next cotton candy recipe
we're gonna be making a cotton candy ice
cream sandwich this one is an ode to the
fair foods because i miss the summer
county fairs and this is essentially
just an ice cream cookie sandwich but
instead of the cookies you have cotton
candy and i know it seems like a lot a
lot of sugar because it is let's not
dwell on it it's 20 20 we've seen
scarier so going back to our cotton
candy machine which i've already let
heat up again let's drop in two pink
candies
turn it back on
this is so fun okay so i'm gonna stick
it in 45 degree angle and then slowly
roll it
around
and i'm gonna take it off and press it
into this three inch round mold there it
is all nice and compact and now let's do
it again with the blue
again making sure it's nice and compact
and we're
good
let's go get our ice cream so you might
have seen this trick before but we're
going to use a serrated knife and we're
going to cut a one inch disk
into the entire pint
once you have that we're going to remove
the packaging the bottom layer is going
to be the blue cotton candy i'm going to
put it right on top right there
[Music]
and then top it with our pink cotton
candy that is massive i'm just going to
press it down
once your cotton candy ice cream
sandwich looks something like this we
are ready to move on to the next step
i'm gonna pour in a third cup of
sprinkles into a tupperware look how
pretty these are there's like little
unicorn heads pretty pastel colors so
the last step is to take our cotton
candy ice cream sandwich and just roll
it into the sprinkles you could do it
nice and slow
and just make sure it's all nice and
covered and there you have it a cotton
candy ice cream sandwich this looks
really good i love the pink and blue
classic cotton candy flavors we have
unicorn ice cream and unicorn sprinkles
which i think are absolutely adorable
let's take a bite cheers
mmm
i've never had anything like this before
wow
it's so sweet i love it
[Music]
and that's enough for me
[Music]
all right guys we've reached the final
cotton candy recipe for today and this
is the cotton candy cake i put it in
quotes because it's not a real cake but
it'll be presented like a cake before we
get to eat it like regular cotton candy
all right the cotton candy machine has
finished heating up i'm going to turn it
off so i can add in the white coloring
which is a yellow candy and fine white
sugar i always get really anxious
because i'm not sure when it'll start
spitting out the
cotton candy
why is it crying are you okay
oh i don't know how to help you
ah
this cake recipe is a little labor
intensive because you can't just make
all the colors at once we're going to
need to make it and then put it in a
tupperware because if we leave it out
the cotton candy will melt
this is the best day of my life
this is so cool
i have my first color and i'm grabbing
this six inch deep tupperware and i'm
just going to slide this in here
and then
press it in
i'm not going to press it in too hard
and while we make the other colors we're
going to cap our tupperware so it's
airtight and we're going to put in the
fridge this way it won't melt let's
start with the purple so that when we
invert it we can have our roiji bib on
our cotton candy i'm gonna start with
three purple candies
okay guys i laid out all the candies i
have
i ran out of purple so i mixed red and
blue and i know you might be thinking
wow
she's really good but somehow i got
white i'm just gonna keep adding more
red and blue hoping that once this
really builds up it'll be purple i feel
like the color becomes more prominent
when there's more stuff together you
know what this looks more purple than
the purple candy did so i'm happy with
this okay it definitely looks purple now
so we're gonna put this in the
tupperware and then do the rest of the
colors
we have our final layer here we're just
going to put it on the top of the
tupperware press it down with the lid
now we are going to
take the lid off of our oh no
there we go nothing happened now let's
invert it
so once you figure out how many slices
you want you can go ahead and stick your
little candles in there
i am doing six and on top of our candles
here we're going to add in our flames
which i have assorted gummies for a
peach one can go here
you can do cherry over here
watermelon on either side
oh so cute and those will be your
candles and there you have it a cotton
candy cake now we can just take a slice
right here you can
eat your flame
i'm gonna eat the rest like regular
cotton candy
the purple layer changes colors
throughout because i had that trouble
with the purple candies in the beginning
and mixing colors but it actually turned
out quite cute i think this cotton candy
cake is a really fun way to play up
cotton candy and the rainbow colors are
so vibrant
all right guys there you have it three
must try cotton candy recipes again if
you don't have a cotton candy machine no
worries at all all of these recipes work
with pre-made cotton candy if you end up
making any of these make sure to take a
picture and tag me on instagram and if
you want to see more of my content make
sure to subscribe to bring me bye guys
oh yes
[Music]
you